the Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein and FBI director Christopher
Rea appeared on Capitol Hill earlier
today there they clashed with some House
Republicans who accused the Department
of Justice of hiding information from
Congress here's part of the exchange if
you have evidence that this president
acted inappropriately presented to the
American people there's an old saying
that justice delayed is justice denied I
think right now all of us are being
denied whatever you got finish it the
hell up because this country is being
torn apart with regard to the
investigation I've heard the suggestions
that we should just close the
investigation I think the best thing we
can do is finish it appropriately and
reach a conclusion tom Fitton is the
president of Judicial Watch and he joins
us tonight Tom when is this gonna wrap
up did we get any sense of an end date
for the Russian investigation no there's
there's no imminent end date this
obstruction investigation into Trump's
firing or call me who knows when that's
going to end and of course you've got
the Russia collusion investigation we
know there's been no Russia collusion
with President Trump so well I don't
know what ballers doing he hasn't
presented any information about where he
is in his investigation frankly he
should be up on the hill testifying
since he seems the one seems to be the
one running the Justice Department and
the FBI on this important matter so how
did they respond ray and Rosenstein
under these questions well you know they
seem I think oblivious to the concerns
Americans have about the credibility of
the leadership of the Justice Department
and the FBI obviously under the Obama
administration it was an absolute
disaster but they don't want to grapple
with that cut the fact that Congress
doesn't trust them to turn over all the
documents they have and certainly
director ray doesn't seem to think that
the IG report was even about the FBI he
keeps on thinking
it wasn't about the institution of the
FBI but some people who happen to work
there when in fact it was the leadership
of the FBI that was severely ethically
compromised during the Obama
administration well into the Trump
administration and and mr. Rosenstein
you know has a dozen excuses as to why
the documents aren't being produced in a
timely way to Congress and those are
decisions by the Justice Department not
to comply with subpoenas in a timely way
and he doesn't have any good excuses as
to why it takes years and months to turn
over basic text information why certain
texts weren't turned over and when it
pressed on it he says well I've got a
lot of people working on it very hard
and if they miss it and there are
mistakes that are made I go back and I
share that your concerns with them it's
it doesn't sound very satisfying anyone
who's trying to get answers about the
most significant corruption issue in a
generation know it's so evasive and on
and by I don't know about you I used to
be impressed by the DOJ in the FBI this
is really sad to watch Tom great to see
you thank you hey Thank You Tucker